si vous êtes passés au cours des
derniers jours à l'aéroport jean-lesage
à québec et vous avez peut-être remarqué
la présence de chiens dans l'aéroport
c'est un projet pilote qui commence
aujourd'hui qui est lancée par
l'aéroport mais en collaboration avec le
cégep de la pocatière donc un programme
en stratégie d'intervention en
zoothérapie
je retrouve amy lee martin qui est
enseignante à un zoo thérapie au cégep
de la pocatière bonjour bonjour et nous
de ce projet pilote d aux thérapies à
l'aéroport oui donc c'est un projet
pilote qui va avoir une durée de deux
mois pour qu'on puisse réévaluer le tout
et puis on commence à d'ailleurs l'a
officiellement cet après midi bien que
le lancement il ya eu lieu cette semaine
mais on commence avec les étudiantes
déjà cet après midi le entre 2h et 4h
avec un chien donc bien entendu on va
alterner aussi les chiens mais ça permet
vraiment de développer les compétences
même raffiner leurs compétences aux
étudiants stagiaires dans un milieu on
va le dire inédit quand même vraiment ça
c'est sûr que les étudiantes à la basse
et toutes des intervenantes dans
relation devrait donc pas avoir des
enseignantes aussi des éducatrices
spécialisées tout ce qui vaut qu'ils
vont vraiment déployer aussi pu mettre
en pratique nouvelles modalités
d'intervention qui est la zoothérapie
auprès des passagers pour leur faire
vivre une belle expérience les racontez
nous comment ça va fonctionner
concrètement pour les voyageurs la cie
par exemple quelqu'un prend un vol
aujourd'hui à jean lesage à québec
qu'est ce qui peut avoir comme service
donc il sait surtout nous le plus gros
du travail va se passer à deux côtés la
zone sécurisée
mais une fois que les gens qui ont
vraiment enregistré leurs bagages puis
que tout ce qui est fait une fois qu'ils
sont de l'autre côté les commencent un
truc que ça se détendent les vraiment
désert aménagé où l'oeil peuvent
s'asseoir tout ça
nous on va circuler vraiment à travers
je dirais ça coûtait leur de larrau par
et puis les gens qui sont intéressés y
vont venir faire notre rencontre souvent
l'a fait d'avoir un animal
suscite la curiosité tout ça et il ya
beaucoup d'ouverture la caisse créée
dans déjà les fois où je suis allé avec
mon chien partant dans l'intervention
les gens venaient vers nous les enfants
également
donc le sacrifice des changes il ya des
choses sont nommés entre autres par
rapport au stress
l'excitation la fébrilité avant leur
voyage le départ des fois l'étranger
pour aller travailler là-bas tout ça
donc il le l'animal whittom ce qu'un
prétexte
mais c'est évidemment partenaire de
travail avec lequel on travaille en
collaboration et il est bon rang qui a
contacté votre sujet pour tenter de
mettre en place un projet comme celui-là
c'est exact oui parce qu'il voyait qu'il
y avait un besoin aussi de ce côté là
pour certains passagers et puis donc de
fil en aiguille en discutant tous on ne
put vraiment mettre en place le système
là qui nous permettrait de pouvoir le
créer ce partenariat là et pour toujours
nos passagers c'est quoi l'objectif
ultime là d'un projet pilote comme celui
là qu'est ce qui fait en sorte que vous
diriez passé c'est une réussite ce qu'on
est en train de faire oh mon dieu
en fait c'est vraiment je pense déjà
les commentaires des passagers le à
l'égard la présence d'un animal le fait
que
ils puissent nous nommer que déjà ça les
apaise que ça les rassure que ça leur
fait du bien
puis de créer facilement ce lien là avec
eux puis bien il ya des enfants qui sont
stressés prendre l'avion également par
souvent aux adultes mais il ya cet
élément lemoine j percevoir vraiment
j'avais mes raisons
c'est un temps tout vous avez dit c'est
un endroit inédit de faire les autres
thérapies dans un aéroport
c'est quand même ça déjà été lancés dans
d'autres dans d'autres lieux comme ça
dans deux aéroports au pays
ça fonctionne oui oui oui absolument
puis ils y ont vraiment des bonnes
rétroaction de ce côté là quoique nous
notre démarche est tout de même
différente par le fait que nous c'est
vraiment avec des étudiants qui font une
formation l'intervention de zoothérapie
donc c'est ça la différence alors que le
c'est sûr que je peux pas vous donner
les détails sur leur démarche à eux mais
nous c'était vraiment dans cette optique
le connais des gens qui puissent être
formés sur place puis toujours supervisé
par un enseignant en tout temps avec des
animaux qui sont des chiens qui sont
évalués le pourra voir aussi les
capacités t'adapter un tel environnement
c'est clair avec une préparation bien
particulière une aire de repos aussi
pour les siens qui font des
interventions de deux heures m'a-t-on
dit amélie en terminant est ce qu'une
possibilité que ce programme là
deviennent permanents à jean lesage
écoutez moi je pense bien coup il le fut
très positif parce que déjà 2 comme
encore on ne put ou mettez en place les
et oui absolument
moi je pense je suis très positif de ce
côté là et bien je vous le souhaite je
le souhaite aussi tout particulièrement
aux voyageurs qui pensent par l'aéroport
donc jean lesage à québec amélie martin
merci beaucoup au projet pilote
merci au revoir